Oh up what night right wait
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil to
know welcome back to presume some like
that isn't that the way the original win
okay anyway I'm back so we have
literally everything in the whole police
station I'm pretty sure there's not a
nuke there's not a cranny there is
nothing that has not been fully explored
in the entirety of everything so we need
to get back down number one first and
foremost so also these high-powered
round I could get I could get the
high-powered gun back out here and then
have that and that would be something
helpful for something maybe I don't know
reload oh no man what the hell oh yeah
that doors just open but they don't come
in here because they know better no no
no switch back switch back okay there
you go
alright so now that got that oh oh I
don't need those who needs those anyway
I don't even know how to make those so
why would I know why would I know how to
do anything with those anyway I'm gonna
keep one grenade in my inventory just
one and that's it
I'm good to go how's my health caution
perfect love riding it caution yeah yeah
alright that took way too long to get
the premise of what I was doing going so
I'm going back down you get
it's that [ __ ]
whoa-ohh here where what Marvin did you
invade my personal space I don't
appreciate if you did but I'm thinking
that you did anyway whatever that's not
the point the point is that I have
enough and I'm getting by with enough
I'm like playing this game for some
reason on hardcore with myself and I
don't know why but I'm probably gonna do
that after I'm done with the game maybe
for a scream or something it's because I
actually I really like this game
I remind me of like slowly exploring
every nook and cranny in Dead Space it
very much reminds me of that and I love
that maybe I would enjoy playing
Resident Evil 4 I bet I would
okay if I recall there's plenty of
enemies right out here oh but they're
not here okay hang on wait a second okay
so there's a piece in there but I also
need to go down there let me go down
this way first cuz I need to just double
check that everything is cool and if
everything is not cool then we OH
everything's not cool all right what do
we got here mate wait maybe that's gonna
be a different tape than the one before
and maybe they would offer me a little
bit more insight as to what's going on
over here all right you guys have fun up
there I'll I'll be back in a bit I gotta
just I gotta just double check some
stuff oh okay wait wait whoa whoa whoa
okay hang on wait wait Chuck
okay why else come of me
okay all right big boom in coming home
jiminy Christmas why you got to be such
a way how you do it babe
hello wink gone goodbye and point oh
sorry man I'm real that's such shame
anyway you guys have a good night I am
out of anything so that's good
this was unfortunate and it's not my
fault that I'm out of everything because
it's not like I was being careless with
my supplies a week and point I was being
very careful actually hello oh good not
why do you do that why do you do that
every time right so I've just got big
boomy and then bigger boo me I've got no
grenades left but that's okay because
grenades are for wimpy babies and I am
anything but a wimpy baby so long as I'm
not doing what they want me to do oh
yeah that goes nowhere but there's
probably some supplies over here and
hopefully not a surprise over here yeah
okay that'll do all right that's it
apparently okay God what I need I forget
what this connects back up to where I
was going before but I just don't
remember where or how but I got the
thing that I need to open this so it's a
start and then once I get back up now
that I've killed those two zombies
they've followed me down it should be
clear that I can pull that chest piece
out or not pull the chest piece out and
go down the way that it was going before
I think this is the one that yeah this
is the one that was broken so what's
down here this loops back I know this
loops back but I just don't remember
where exactly
oh here okay alright then I don't need
to go here then I can go back and then I
can go up the other way and then I can
get by those guys that I shot and then I
can go that way grab the chest pieces
only one more chest piece that I would
need to grab and then I'm good to go so
just a quick skedaddle back I've got all
the cool things that I need and no
worries here right right there's the
other room down lock here some dead guys
there hit or miss I guess I've never met
soon okay hello oh yeah this is nothing
in here
Hey look gunpowder Oh Andy I was like
when they gave me gunpowder it's always
very very helpful in one way or another
what's down here and where does this
connect up oh hello hi
rah I know right raids yeah where are
you going
you're it oh yeah oh well
that probably didn't finish you off but
whatever really Billy buddy you're gonna
make me use one of these oh maybe not
universe oh I got use this now because
you bit my ankle in what world
yeah oh yeah oh you got no arms what are
you gonna do nothing yes there you're
done you're done okay you're done
forever I eat my Wheaties and you're
done huh
okay well that was a nightmare glad I
did that is this only a drop-off I think
this is only a drop-off there's really
no point to this in any way shape or
form other than dropping off into here
which I'm not gonna do cuz I don't feel
like going down the lower waterway just
yet so I'm just gonna get this thing and
I'm gonna go on my way cuz that was a
big waste of time I did not need to
fight that guy whatsoever it didn't even
have a valuable item ID me I'd wasted
all my bullets man well that's a shame
but whatever okay I'm just gonna take
this and be on my way
alright we're good I eat my Wheaties I'm
a hundred percent good these are both
done apparently and this goes in this
goes in let me watch this video
hopefully it's different than the one
before but then again maybe not and if
it's not that it's not yeah same videos
before everything's cool that's great
good yeah I feel good alright so this
one just goes in here and I think that's
it right
yeah what are you talking about did I
get him wrong again with this the bishop
is this the bishop yeah that's the
bishop oh did he always changed okay
wait
rooks next to the night but not facing
the Queen okay so they changed it they
got a do know they changed it looks next
this is my not facing the Queen all
right they change it's different oh I'm
sorry
King eight next to the Queen but when
but facing the night right at the end
and the night ain't where the case
marking says it is what okay I've got
all the pieces so rooks next to the
night but not facing the Queen the Queen
ain't next to the King but facing the
night right at the end and the knight
ain't where the case marking says it is
so logically speaking the Knights
probably over here which means the King
is facing it on the end because it would
not be on this one so the Kings here
facing there the rook is next to it not
facing the Queen the Queen's not next to
the knight the pawns probably where it
says it is and then that means the rook
is here and the Queen is here boom oh
come on that's holy [ __ ] you and dick me
ah this is annoying because that's what
it says that is a solution of what it
says so if this is not the orientation
where the King is over here facing this
right at the end then that means that
the pawn plug isn't also not where it
says it is that's what I'm getting out
of this okay if it doesn't say that the
pawn isn't where it's supposed to be I
can only assume that the pawn has to be
there because otherwise it starts to
fall apart it doesn't really make sense
so the only caveat is the knight can't
be there that means means the Knights
over here right oh my god I've done this
every [ __ ] way that you could do this
what the [ __ ] all right I can't get that
right now I'm gonna forget about it for
now I'm gonna let my brain simmer and
I'm gonna go upstairs because I
remembered there's a
occurred that I haven't unlocked down
gonna go unlock I forgot there's from
zombies up here hey bud who did that
no no no no listen but in ski I just
feel like this further
cuz I'm annoyed what what had to happen
anyway
hit or miss cuz i never miss srz I think
szf how's it all right what did I get
what's my prize all bullets yeah I
needed those actually that's a pretty
good prize I needed that oh wait oh wait
ah I'm so done the rook is not the
bishop oh oh I'm a ninny I was reading
this the rook is next to the night for
some reason I was thinking rook is
bishop
I am very dumb I'm very dumb
I'm very dumb I'm very dumb okay I need
to I hey I got a I think if this is the
same fight as was before I got to get
grenades I'm gonna get grenades I'm
gonna get just two grenades cuz I think
there's gonna be one on the ground over
there and I'm gonna need these in order
to beat the snot out of that piece of
[ __ ] so let's do this I think I feel
dumb but I'm okay all right everybody
ignore that I know that took a lot
longer than you guys suspected it would
but yeah hey you know me always keeping
things interesting always making it nice
and spicy for you you know how I like to
spice it up a little bit I'm a spicy
kind of guy
I'm very spicy I'm a spicy man right
power must be you know how it is okay
I'm a spicy man spicy man coming through
spice man with the plan
spicy playing man anyway sure okay look
it's a whole smorgasbord all right
anything else in here nah that's it all
right let's get this puzzle there we go
easy and then nothing bad is going to
ever lalalalalalala Wow Jesus oh boy yay
Yaya Yaya no need to be grabby no no no
no no oh god damn it
okay really you're gonna get me that way
you were over there I heard you you
weren't even close to where I was okay
the long as I just keep moving oh oh oh
hey buddy how you doing I'm just gonna
run right by you don't mind me just
sneaking gone by anything I missed
yeah you know I don't think he's the
dying type oh oh yeah the crane yeah I
remember okay I know the crane
okay let's see if I can actually do this
on the first go which is very doubtful
but you know dreamers can dream hey
buddy
hey listen there is no need do I have
the right thing equipped no I do not
okay here we go
all right listen listen come here come
here Olay Oh Land Olay ah can i okay ow
all right that's not close enough oh
[ __ ] I didn't even do it right oh I'm
such an idiot
okay come here please charge Oh duh all
right stay there oh he would
I didn't even did you do that he was
gonna go down anyway
ah hey ugly how you doing I mean
beautiful beautiful man if that is your
real name Wow okay that that really
smarts let me just please choke down
some herbs real quick that's real smart
hat says hurts hurts real bad no wow she
sums you are just a sack a sash
wow really really really oh really all
right come here you know Oh God oh [ __ ]
I didn't expect you to grab me then that
was not part of the plan that was
annoying okay whatever is fine I'll get
it hi bud okay I gotta learn to dodge
you cuz this aim this eight holdin this
ain't holdin out don't
not necessary
oh geez sums okay all right Wow really
rude number one and number two get over
here don't grab me don't grab me don't
grab me
okay well that's all right I guess I'm
gonna die goodbye
I guess I'm dead hey bud everybody Wow
okay lesson of the days don't go
straight for the claw that's coming at
ya try to go around it okay it's just no
avoiding you all right can you uh no not
that one can you please just no just oh
my god are you serious are you [ __ ]
serious are you serious right now are
you soon you'll I'm gonna get hit by
this and you can all really yeah that's
so wonderful
that's wonderful yeah that's that's what
I was hoping for ah that's what I was
hoping for this is great this is going
real good
if you both know [ __ ] off with your
dumbing it down I don't need you to dumb
it down just cuz I don't know what a
rook from a bishop doesn't mean that I
need your L stupid oh hey god it's so
annoying you are the most annoying guy
you're the most annoying ow
okay that's not come over here no God
not the grab wyden you sack of [ __ ]
you are just the mossad to kill me just
kill me just kill me just do it you stay
right there stay right there
stay right there I'll do it again if I
have to get hit get hit get hit get hit
okay it's fine
this is going great Wow Wow
really no need for that you're being
quite difficult actually Oh God oh geez
low no no no no no notes whatever
whatever just whatever God you suck you
suck so much I poked him in his eye I
really hope I did cuz I would died hope
I did Wow what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] god you're such a piece of
crap you suck so much I don't even have
I don't even have what I need anymore to
get done with you you're so annoying why
why that that's awful
stop that stop that stop whatever you're
doing to stop it just get over here so I
can trap you with this [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah okay alright okay yeah I don't
how alright let's uh let's just go for
this I don't have a grenade anymore even
though I could have gotten them all this
I'll miss is what I'll do on this okay
stay right there get hit get hit
oh okay
[Music]
ah
got'em easy peasy easiest easiest thing
I've ever done in my life
take it forever pay whatever I ain't
worried about nothing that didn't take
no more than four or five tries sherry
how are you doing you alive I bet you're
not sherry
good mom sherry Claire sherry are you
alright
yeah what are you doing I'm here to help
since you don't seem to be able to she
can't be saved you're her mother
get in here this conversation is over
wait okay yeah okay all right sure yeah
there's long enough time millions of
lives are at stake
sherry mommy loves you sweetie
goodbye
um birds you seem to have your your
priorities on a bit of a carousel here
because I care thank you I'm sure my
heart grew three times the size that day
I have to carry your ass
oh well that's hindering on my shooting
ability yeah well and that's a liar that
cable car probably all right sherry just
rub your infected eye into my shoulder
there I can't even save it's it's fine I
didn't need to whatever
goodbye hello how are you is that zombie
still there you're fine sherry zombie Oh
God oh I guess they didn't want anything
getting in the way all right almost
there just a long cable car ride away
don't you worry about two shakes of a
lamb's it da cable car good grade yes
this looks real nice this looks totally
safe real nice that looks that looks
that looks just fine that looks okay
yeah fine
better check everything oh well I got
everything I'm pretty sure I think I got
everything why does this say there's
still like something in the monitor room
did I not get everything in the monitor
did I not get everything in the control
room did I not get anything everything
everywhere I am an ass all right I'm
gonna make one last sweep before I go
okay it looks like I've got everything
so I'm assuming even though it's red in
here I don't know why but yeah I think
I've got everything what does this say
electronic part plug socket adds
everything that's everything I don't
need to worry about it's all good for
some reason it's because there's parts
of the peasel stuck in there and that's
all that I need I didn't get anything
else I don't have anything new I'm good
to go I'm ready I'm excited let's do
this Lock and Load baby I found one
grenade let's do this Sherri I know you
got all the time in the world with that
infection coursing through your eyeball
but don't worry about we're going for it
going quick we're going fast run furious
don't tell me how to live my life
because I am NOT one for following rules
oh I gave her my jacket it fits her
really oddly well you want some herbs
spices got eleven of them
you're sorry yes
I don't know what I'd do without you
are you kidding me
you were doing just fine without me if I
came along and got you all sorts of
trouble
I have something here's
really why not so pretty
it's from my mom
for my birthday last year I really
wanted was for her to be home more I
know it seems like your mom
yeah laying down is really doing you no
good she don't look so good give you a
booster shot or something I'll find some
weird chemicals in the lab and I'll just
I don't start slapping some [ __ ]
together good here you look awfully gray
and yeah not so good yeah well whatever
it's probably fine yeah yeah tell me
about it if you vomit don't vomit on me
okay just let me know you stick your
head over the railing don't vomit on me
that's all I'm asking again I don't
follow rules I don't like rules I don't
like people that make rules I'm enjoying
my visit hello can I pop you up on
something here okay never mind
great couch no okay well I guess I got
this burden not that you're a burden
okay never mind how about over here
sure what is it security room perfect
perfect perfect so safe safe that safe
can be ignore all that other blood
that's weird
that looks technical yeah it's gotta be
it
cool Hey hey sherry I gotta go would you
stay right here though okay
I'll be back soon I promise
I don't know how I knew about that I
don't think there was anything good that
gave Claire an idea of what how
important that thing was but whatever
she's smart she could figure it out I
guess all right dude North Area
immediately use devil antiviral only way
to prevent gene mutation if you have
been infected with the g-virus seek
immediate help immediately to target
destroy the G cells in your body all
right well that's great where is this
devil huh where's the devil Devils in
the details
all right and grenade it's for some
reason we got grenades okay let's do
this ha Boesky and in here and give me a
sweet save why is it red I thought it
was red Oh
keep this right here I've got that this
is probably pretty good maybe I should
get the spark shot happens a lot of
space I won't get in till I need it I
mean it's right here what's the worst
that could happen was there something on
the wall over there hello yes I dearest
bands okay I already knew that whatever
oh hello
Oh nap room log oh look at all these
naps
eisah bunching naps so nice nappy all
right boink I wonder if they're in here
uh-huh
sounds ominous sounds fun
hello alright how's it going BAM gotcha
you done no he's not done
there we go dead alright who else is
here who is there some more people right
someone crunching munching yeah how you
doing hey how you go about for another
buy please thank you
sneak attack does bonus damage oh hello
who's there oh hey how you doing oh okay
those should have been hits damn Blume
okay well goodbye haha alright
Oh needle cartridges just right there
hopefully [ __ ] you know the people
needed their cafeteria food to be so
shocking you're not dead
gotcha oh you're not dead okay I see how
it is you better be dead for good this
time
okay easy enough and I didn't get
everything apparently where is the
secret bonus supply that you are hiding
from me because if you're hiding it from
me I'm going to be very upset there we
go grenade nice good bonus oh there's
more there's more
what is it more of or is this just
connecting to the other place over there
probably blue is that it no that's not
it
nice good great all done okay that's
everything
don't be silly like that are you stay
down for now oh you got that Cup - no
you stay down for now okay you come here
electronic chip combine that good got it
easy
okay I don't have this but I don't need
that and I have
[Applause]
that's nice that's pretty nice okay
that's nice he's gonna really do a
number on those plant-based things
probably let's combine this with that oh
yeah
yes Bree that's pretty peppy all right
let's uh let's store this let's just go
ahead and take out the ammo for this bad
boy let's put this bad boy away cuz
that's doing me no good uh do I need the
grenade launcher when I have this stuff
it's really debatable but you know it'll
hold on to it I guess I don't really
need a grenade so I'm gonna store that
one away I'm good on health I don't need
a knife but I'm gonna hold onto a knife
just in case all right all right
we're loaded up we're ready to go let's
kick some ass baby hey sherry how you
doing Bob sherry
all right good hair hey how you doing
okay
see round all right yes leap tight ah
very interesting very interesting
oh they gave me the scrambler right here
oh well yay cool signal modulator uh-huh
that's the only reason that I need to be
here Leon's here blowing [ __ ] up but I'm
here just being a badass where'd that
guy go oh he's gone
uh-oh all right let's this is awesome
done babe oh I'm gonna get an upgraded
pouch I forgot that's here yes
oh hello and also you hello you that's
gonna go right skate right by you know
I'm too smart I'm too smart to die I'm
too smart too smart
there's more to dive juice bar swings
man my smartness is too smart
Yoho Yoho off door we go
I hear you I hear you loud and clear you
always wanted to be a pirate in life you
can only be a part in death I get it
do do you this place is very impressive
I'm very impressed by this place which
is very impressive extremely impressive
in fact most impressive impressive
actually improve
improv is impossible is very
impressionable this place it's
impregnable you can't pregnat it it's
impregnable you KITT it's too impressive
very impressed hello can you save me
from myself and my own stupidity no okay
goodbye
all right Lu Lobby yay new save area not
that I really need to save but you know
how it is I'm a bit of a worrywart
I'm gonna try to keep it under 30 so
I'll that's gonna be the only save in
this area maybe probably that's a lie
it's not like Anna definitely not gonna
hold true to that that's no way in hell
that I'm actually gonna do that yeah
whatever you know back keep lying but
you know it's it's okay it's chill I
can't go this way right that clock
doesn't work but I know it's 3:00 a.m.
that's blocked out there all right let's
do this oh oh yeah that's right gross
gross hello how are you
yeah god that's sound yeah okay time to
test out the zapo Matic 9000 here we go
here we go baby and pulling oh yeah
there it is there it is there it is oh
you get fried up that's good
it works out quite nicely actually
alright flashbang need the dispersal
thing but what I really gotta do is I
just gotta find a cure for this [ __ ]
oh yeah okay sure would have been nice
to flee on what had done the work for me
already and taken care of this but I
guess I got to do it myself again do I
remember what these were are these the
same probably not yeah yeah yeah damn it
it's definitely not the same codes as it
was before probably not that make it too
easy okay I see how it is all right what
do we got here what are we working with
what are we doing who do we gotta shoot
who do I gotta shoot why okay you get
shot
Zippy's happy to be zappy cook are you
dead
how are you not dead what you better
stay dead
I wish the full charge on you that's
supposed to kill you maybe because you
weren't oh there you go there you go
there you go now he's got that got him
oh yeah that really did him in yeah it
did him in pretty good what can I say
pretty decent at what I do okay what are
you you are that I come here you come
here you nice answer : yaiii
enter : yaaayyy
okie dokie easy-peasy yeah this is the
music in this area really bugs me all
these creatures with their glue penis I
just don't like creatures that are extra
poopy I just don't feel the need it's
unnecessary Oh doll I can't read it
hey buddy you mind if I take this yeah
use it a grenade are you I would aside
to see our grenade anyway okay you got
everything in here no but probably cuz
of that I'll come back for it anyway I
don't have enough space as it is just so
yeah so black why is it so black where
can I steal from you more gunpowder
great love it a map excellent love it my
inventory is full my expanded inventory
that I just spent time on expanding is
now fall for some reason
oh yeah all right here we go hello I
know this just circles back so it's a
good thing that I'm here that's closed
off but until I get the power but I have
the power thing right now so I can go
ahead and do this Oh what is that flame
rounds perfect love it oh now now don't
be a little [ __ ] no need to be any sort
of a [ __ ]
you hear me earth I like earth earth you
got it earth Murph is in F is up earth
is done and everyone is fine I'm just
getting this out to preemptively do
something in case anything very licky
decide ah right how about one of these
I'm just gonna do this this is gonna
work right god dammit didn't get the
other one all right well you get one of
these special treatment hello goodbye
alright good that one well don't get up
I will hurt you okay that's all we need
it over here and I need to go back to
the server room for something right
unless the server room is something else
was this the cold area this wasn't the
cold area was it no this is just a
server room okay I can combine these two
for more of that okay good more of these
always nice hey look it's a safe oh I
forgot this was here let me do this
first um put this way put this way put
this here do I have more blue no I don't
but that's okay so much gunpowder I
should probably do something with that
all right we're good save maybe always a
good idea hello Oh knife I don't need
another knife I've got so many knives I
should probably use them probably in
just imagine it's gonna be so awesome
no no no no there you go
no what the hell all right hang on wait
gotta eat my Wheaties I'm gonna get you
with one of these okay that's what I
thought that's what you deserve
oh hey it's the award uh well it's a
trophy well what's on the bottom of the
trophy I might ask Wow very helpful very
helpful indeed okay so I don't think I
need to go here just yet
um I'm going to burst through here and
circle back around I'm gonna unlock the
phase left
hey don't how about you don't know about
you doing it probably would have been
faster to go the other way at this point
no Wow okay that's that's moderately
concerning oh [ __ ] I forgot I needed to
keep it on there oh I'm okay we're gonna
go that was a waste of a shot but I'll
forgive myself somehow I'll learn to
forgive myself not today maybe not even
tomorrow but I'll learn someday to
forgive myself oh hey buddy how you
doing um whoa that was a scream hey you
don't okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
thank you thank you for your input very
very valuable I really appreciate it I
probably didn't need to go this way
probably not the best but I did as a
matter of fact I did manage to utilize
the things that I came here to utilize
which is important do I have another
yeah I do okay let's take this out let's
combine this boom baby I think I'm done
with that but it still says I need to
use it so I'm gonna hold onto it for a
little bit somebody come get some get me
and get some oh hey how you doing okay
listen you need to stop do the funny
dance and
okay there you go and goodbye how are
you back up no that's that should very
much be impossible
oh come on you should not be alive again
you should have been very dead I don't
like that I had to use to I'm gonna use
a flame round on the next one just
because you bastards are trying my
patience a little bit new cute e reverse
pac-man : okay
new cute e reverse pac-man : hey both
key you guys so you guys are still alive
this that's not that's not right that's
not what it's supposed to be I don't
like the shocker I thought it would have
done you real good
but apparently it did not do you - good
and you I'm just you're too good for the
shocker is what it is okay um this
shouldn't be too hard okay I got this I
know how to do this yeah I know how to
do this yeah you think you're smart but
the truth is you you are not I know what
you want
boom baby bottle boosts ki baat abisco
bottom biscuit I'll abolish go bit of
its go BBB blue doo-doo-doo got that
okay I need to put that there and I need
to cool immediately so I'm going to cool
immediately even if they're [ __ ] in
my way
hey look at [ __ ]
why are you too tough for this just stop
being alive no god damn you you suck
should have put the barrel on you excuse
me I'm on fire she has me she has makes
me I should have put the goddamn Barrel
on you probably walking through fire is
not good for cooling the solution but
I'm gonna pretend like that didn't
happen does it might as well not if I am
being very wasteful with my ammo I don't
like it
good thing I don't have my jacket that
would be horrible right here and now
your parka yeah you silly Billy you
silly silly
ah funny
thank you that took a while but thank
you again a very complicated process
just to cool something down and I feel
like it could have done done a lot a lot
quicker but oh well gunpowder yeah
that's probably useful okay that's
everything
let's get EOD and let's go spray some
[ __ ] is there gonna be another guy
alive here because if there is I'm gonna
be very pale aliased not so far not as
far as thus oh you
I see these little balls on your body or
the balls what I needed
whatever just yeah
that's horrible God every time every
time I was doing so good I was from Oz
eat my Wheaties I'm doing so good and
then you gotta come by and you got to
make me feel like [ __ ]
you gotta come by you're gonna make me
feel bad because you think that I am
just a buffet that you can come snack on
at any time and it's not true and I
don't like you for thinking that I got
so much goddamn gunpowder but it's fine
cuz I'm gonna use my other quick-draw
army get this back in there move this
there give me the good ammo yeah all
right let me fill this up there we go
are we happy now are we happy are we
happy are we gonna be happy are we gonna
stay happy
put this in number two we're good to go
I don't need to save I need to save cuz
it's about to get real tyrant T up in
here maybe if he's still alive because
maybe he's not I don't know whatever I
don't know how he's gonna be these guys
better not still be alive
I'ma be real pissed how the pecking peck
oh hey don't mind me disperse it baby I
don't know why these guys turn to two
plants anyway it's pretty horrible if
you think about it and there she goes
goodbye very sorry glum Lumberton okie
dokie
uh-huh weird huh well that's that's not
a good sign
all right hello you all right you guys
alive is a tyranny er no no tyrant
okay how about how about some of this
there you go you dad you better actually
be dead this time the way I came no
actually no not because there's less
hostiles this way slide down here that's
all I needed
why did I needed the the wristband
that's right the wristband that's the
only reason I needed to go through all
this what a roundabout way to save a
little girl
it's weird I guess the tyrant really
isn't a problem right now anymore for
some reason not sure why but apparently
not oh oh that sounds bad
yo yo ho yo ho it's off to work we go
goodbye I'm running away now I just
don't like the music the music is so
disconcerting it's so scary they're
really good at the music in that area
it's just so scary I got all I need
let's get out of here let's get yachty
come on baby okay and three two one West
area here I come
this is about to be interesting yeah I
know I know why I'm here do you know why
you're here because honestly I'm not
sure you do I don't know I'm here I'm
here to try to find my brother Chris
Redfield you know Resident Evil 5 biceps
as big as your brain very nice very nice
this is good this is good there's a good
thing
grenade good thing also a good thing
hello hi how you doing it's me mark EMU
here back at it again Oh AWS you've got
it baby you got it
all right AWS all right AWS oh yeah
there we go
done all right so what did that do
besides turn the lights on anything
important probably not okay anything in
here before I hit that little thing no
oak plant all right
in there probably want me to gear up I
guess I mean it won't be on the way out
won't be yeah whatever
this is probably the same is it whoa
okay no not that that's right I can't
put the plan in the cassette player
that'd be asinine it's stupid I'm not
that alright nothing I haven't seen
before it's all the same all these tapes
are the same it's all the same don't
worry about it tell Matilda your gun
okay whatever all right nothing to see
here nothing important anyway what is it
uh umbrella umbrella umbrella umbrella
g-virus uh kids it's mine it's my virus
it's mine mine the money is mine okay so
I don't think I'm gonna need anything
until we get to the other side because
if I remember correctly there is a
Google dabber on the other side for me
yes no is there I don't remember but if
there's not an I am in trouble because I
do not have nearly enough to go down in
this boss void but if I don't then I
will persevere from all the goodies that
they're gonna give me when I get down
there which of which they are going to
give me many all right what else they
got here hello gun powder perfect love
it something else plant good great love
it
great love that love that as well and
that's all that I get and then combine
this to get that and then I've got that
and I put this away and I I'll take out
the rest of my submachine gun ammo and
then I'll have two of those and one of
these and take take one of these and oh
I can I'll put this here and then I'll
mix this what I just got such the
freshest it could possibly be put that
there and then maybe take out another
grenade and I'm good I've never been so
good let me savor so I can know that I'm
safe I like safety and then I'll put
this here and then I'll do this there
and little bit of Colome
isn't gonna blow up well easy huh easy
huh
[Applause]
really
oh well who's my do
[Music]
what the hell is this thing didn't you
have to shoot him twice before that was
my husband
Oh
Oh yep
I should have killed him while I had the
chance I don't know why I just do it he
was your husband
honestly we were more Meritor work than
each other
what about sharing how could you just
leave her all alone and while Raccoon
City burned to help I couldn't let my
daughter grow up in a world with the
g-virus
ouchies let's fill pepper oh yeah that
ain't good
I got this I'm a badass that's what they
call me up I've noticed the finisher in
many circles and oh okay I've been
called the finisher many times
excuse me apart in me I just thank you
for getting out of my way I really
appreciate you not being a big old [ __ ]
about things oh hey how you doing I'm
just on my me grabbing up oh that looks
oh I ain't on I need my Wheaties and you
you are not giving me time to eat my
Wheaties and I would appreciate it if
you gave me some Wheaties time anyway
I'll see you around the friend just
gathering up my preparatory things that
I need just to kick your ass
I mean haha I mean say hello to your
grave I mean oh good night way way back
oh my Wheaties ally I meant to hit that
before you hit me thank you for the
first aid spray oh hey how you doing hey
all right how you doing hey good to see
ya just gotta gather up all the goodies
okay well yeah I didn't make you even
flinch
all right whatever it's okay I don't
need you to flinch I just need you to
shut up and take some take some wolf
what's good for you oh [ __ ] let you pick
up one of these bad boys pick up pick up
a boo-boo yeah yeah you pick that up and
it's your mistake oh [ __ ] it's still
okay you know I thought that was gonna
be one of those situations where you oh
[ __ ] oh I thought for sure it was gonna
be like one of those you know you regret
what you do so much that you just can't
yeah okay all right you know you're not
listening to me I feel like we're not
communicating on any sort of tangible oh
oh oh that was a lot of blood my
Wheaties defense doesn't seem to be
doing nearly as much can you pick up one
of those goddamn thank you okay now I'm
gonna see if this does this work
there we go that's what I am talking
about and there we go boys over there oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I see you I
see your eye back there that's not good
popped all your eyeballs oh oh wow that
might have killed me okay not quite I'm
still my waves are real tough all right
you know what I'm gonna go throw fancy
oh okay that's that's pretty close to
death it's about as close to death as
I've ever been
oh it was pretty close you really almost
got me there oh I'm in a corner here I'm
kind of backed into a cheesy corner I'm
dead
all right that's that's me that's that's
mine that's me
okay let's forget about that I kept
waiting for an opportunity to do that to
you with you you kept doing
opportunities to me oh [ __ ] oh great you
know what I'm gonna get another Wheaties
bag I'm gonna get another bag of
Wheaties is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
get another bag and when I get another
bag you are gonna get it mister skip
that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay we're starting
oh [ __ ] hey buddy hey
okay and come point why did that not I
feel like that really should do
something to you but it didn't feel that
did something last time Wow
okay am i dead am i Dow well [ __ ] me
it's fine don't worry I've got this now
okay wait wait wait time out time out
time out
thank you for giving me some breathing
room naima widdy's okay whoa where what
did you just pick up where are you oh
gee oh oh jeez oh jeez okay pop one all
right well if I just keep pooping them
Wow alright that was unnecessary okay
why is this being difficult for me there
we go you look fun and fresh alright
this is now going in my favor oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah well how about one of nope
that's oh [ __ ] okay alright throw that
and throw I yeah that's what you get
just get [ __ ] I think that's your Apple
frustrating River chest probably yeah
yeah yeah get some yeah get some hay
well that was easy
well that was easier than easy
the real farty death
nothing says boss defeated like the
fartiest death alive alright I got
everything thanks at least you're not
blowing the whole place up like last
time that's nice that's real nice okay
hey lady how's your daughter alright
good to hear gotta get back to Sherry I
got I got stuff if I don't I don't know
what I'll do I'll lose my mind that
looks like a burst door okay whatever
probably not too much of a concern I've
got so much bullet I am so happy about
that I'll put this away don't eat that
no more this can get this can get gone
yeah yeah oh you know actually I'm gonna
put the submachine gun away cuz I don't
think I need it for now so I'm just
putting it away I've got plenty of this
bullet which is very useful now reload
this and we're good to go we're good
we're good
all right sherry I'm coming back about
time hopefully your mom hasn't done
anything super horrible with you as
Jerry Jerry all better
my mom needs help some spray sure
or how are you okay you don't look so
good
I've got some herbs thank God so sure
he's gonna be all right
she'll be weak for a little while but
yes she's three of the g-virus did you
hear that all right well let's not make
a big deal out of this
it seems we had a lot of pain
tape boycott her to safety
[Music]
sorry [ __ ]
everything
your life is what is hey just leave her
here you're right we can't
what does that mean this is self
destruct code okay g-virus leaves the
building
[Music]
sherry just say goodbye here mom sherry
she loved you okay you really could get
going come on
that's so sad I so much more impactful
than the other version of the ending
again the self-destruct thing I question
it because there's no way to abort it
when it already starts tearing apart the
building but that's all another story
okay
so ah great let's slap that bad boy in
alright
can you walk faster any faster we have
to go alright there comes a time in
everyone's life when they look upon the
fruits of their labors and they
recognize that their own is only one
moment in their entire existence that
will lead them to victory and that
moment is now it is time we've been
sitting on these our entire life and
today keely inspirational music and
today is the day that we does not let
our gunpowder go to waste and we will
use it for as long as we need to use it
for and use it we shall because we know
hang on because we are the only ones
that can use it because we're the only
ones responsible enough to use it and we
will use it with every fiber of our
banal with every fiber of our being we
use this and we have this and we are
this and we is this
this is what we is and this is who we is
being we will use nothing but that which
we is and we have shall be we are the
you things of using it to be and has
used be it by has we do
do you understand be I have two hundred
and thirtysomething bullets I will use
nothing but them in the final
confrontation of if there is one with a
tyrant maybe possibly poss maybe tonight
but if there is that I will use it but
if not then I won't so I go into this
final battle unknown if it is or is not
real or not real we gotta get the hell
out of here and I have using this the
way that it is meant to be you stood
today I deed medicine who needs medicine
when you've got bullets why don't I have
a timer yeah what's up
I'm really glad I met you she's really
glad I met you too sherry but save your
thanks until I get you out of this place
yeah save your deep mature thoughts for
when we get out of here which is
probably definitely going to be
happening am I gonna talk to Leon at all
Leon hey lilo Leon lo leo leo
what Oh spray for hose for out the spray
sherry sherry don't don't be in such a
hurry
uh is there something else I'm missing
well here we go another nice yeah
nothing but knife and bullet that's all
I need come on sherry we got it go
apparently
all right oh that's probably not good
all right sherry whatever may or may not
be coming around this next corner I'm
gonna face it with nothing but knife all
of mine over face it with all of my
knives all of my bullets and maybe
another grenade just what not that many
grenades I don't need that many and
maybe also an herb or two perfect I have
never been more ready for anything in my
entire existence maybe more herb bobble
up on herb now I don't need that much
herb that's probably enough maybe not
the wimpy knives all of my knives and
all of my herbs all right here we go
I'm full of knives herbs and bullets
that's all anybody needs to get
certainly all I need to get by oh
there's the timer I was wondering where
those gonna be all right who's here what
do I need you stay down yeah okay you
stay down yeah Ronnie who needs to stop
for these things not me certainly not me
oh did I miss something there's some in
there whatever it's time for tea oh
hello fry now what I needed but da well
we do do share it you better be behind
me if you're not then you're gonna be in
trouble I don't know what I missed in
but I think it's okay no I don't need
those not the right bullets Jerry all
right sure you hurry up you hurry your
tuchus
so okay oh how did that go Oh
I love all these guns Jerry Jerry
yay thank you Thank You Sheree all right
let's go hurry up please
all right we're good we're fine it's all
good this is the whole way how you doing
man I guess the tyrant really didn't
bite the dust
oh hey okay goodbye
oh hell yeah oh okay well oh how do we
oh I see
do I go in here first probably hello oh
oh please tell me it takes nine
millimeter all of my knives are getting
in the way of this goodness not anymore
apparently
oh [ __ ] I don't have the right thing
where's the power coupler when you need
it
Oh on the train maybe hello whoa okay
sure no there it is god dammit you
telling me I got to drop my knives God
my knives all right but that's the last
one we're right there there we go okay I
need you to stay right here okay okay
good okay always brought such a badass
God so tough
all right this whatever is about to
happen I'm going for it here we go I'm
not gonna use this mini gun at all the
bullets I have to use all my bullets I
can't use the minigun I gotta use my
bullets I think I need to be on there
huh you're down here too
yeah the whole place is coming down
look you need to get out fast I know I
found a way out I think I think we can
all make it where are you now
clear are you still there yeah Leonce
I'm sorry you're breaking up
well buddy don't worry about me just get
out of here Leon Leon Tim oh well win
some lose some taking them all how do I
get back on this thing um bow fancy
Oh Oh something for my bullets oh hey I
got bullets oh wow I got lots of bullets
you want bullets I got lots and Laura I
didn't know you were gonna do that okay
I'll see you around see oh wow you look
fine
you look very fun I have to use all of
my bullets eventually I just have to pee
okay that that was less fun that was
less fun I gotta admit that was a lot
less fun than I thought it'd be Oh
Messer not fun okay how many eyeballs is
one thing need to stay a respectable
distance that's right yeah you do your
thing miss BAE
Oh stupid I don't need the minigun I
know what you're all saying and I don't
need it it's a crutch I earn these
bullets and I'm gonna use every one of
these bullets and pounding these guys
eyes out all right you can't catch me
you can't it's impossible you can't you
simply cannot this guy's got a lot of
health by hard-earned bullets are gonna
pound you into the dirt buddy huh oh wow
that's that's not normal
Wow okay
holy [ __ ] all right my Wheaties can only
hold ups against so much damage and
that's not part of the prescription
you're right there buddy maybe I'm
supposed to use it maybe I can't kill
them fast enough unless I use it but I
refuse to believe that I refuse to
believe that this is unbeatable by
anything but the minigun cuz I earn
these bullets damn it see his eyes are
turning colors that's normal
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh yeah huh
come back here you there you go Wow
all right I'm gettin down to my
nitty-gritty on the bullets well it's
okay
four minutes it's gonna be down to a
wire on this one gonna pop me some
eyeballs that's right yeah you keep
flailing like it
you look so stupid I've never seen
anybody look as stupid as you look right
now oh [ __ ] yeah he's doing the thing
well you look pretty stupid doing it oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay those eyes don't seem to be
changing too much pop pop pop pop pop
pop pop oh [ __ ]
hey that's a lot still a lot of ice so I
feel like maybe hey maybe I've gotten a
bad challenge here maybe I challenged
myself a little too wrongly hey buddy
how you doing oh yeah that's scary
I'll tell you I asked that's real scary
oh how are you oh my god
yiii okay I am almost out of bullets
that I am gonna have to resort to my
knives you want a tussle with this
muscle my knives your ass that's a whole
[ __ ] ocean one clip left two minutes the
whole universe ahead of me I'm ready
this is it the final countdown pop and I
say goodbye oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] okay eat
movies get on my feet ease that's how he
that's how we're gonna win this pop and
I say goodbye oh [ __ ] come on come on
come on come on oh [ __ ]
how many boats Alif not enough all right
time to finish the oh [ __ ] he's he's
going up nice he's going up I don't come
for you baby
Oh Mario ah come back down here we're
gonna fight you come back here I'm gonna
fight you I'm gonna face you with a
knife yeah all right here comes the
Thunder baby oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah you want somebody oh yeah
you can't handle how you can handle it
you can handle it apparently okay Wow
okay you're handling me pretty
succinctly yeah yeah I gotta be close
come on I'll be up close belly up close
come on come on come on come on please
tell me I'm close tell me I'm close come
on oh come on oh come on oh come on oh
no no no danger no danger no danger no
danger eat my Wheaties is this the death
death whale it's the death whale isn't
it
oh please oh please yeah
[Applause]
yeah a nice team the death I knifed him
to death I beat him with my knives
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't believe it I can't believe it
yeah oh yeah all right let's pick up
stupid Leon see where this is gonna go
at pride nothing right surpri don't need
to worry about that
I forget how did Leon get on this train
because that was I don't remember that
uh-huh so it's the first thing you want
to when we get out of here I don't know
oh you guys cream I like ice cream
[Music]
Claire Leon it's so good to see you well
hey you did was this this this is sherry
okay Jesus
whoa oh that I don't know
you stay here with sherry I'm gonna go
check it out
[Music]
okay that's weird
wait a minute oh hello okay and my my
work has been complete I am I'm going
back to my old loadout because I've got
a lot of this high caliber ammo and
probably need to use this stuff for the
high power now I don't have enough high
power to do that so I'm not gonna do
that
the quick army drop put that there put
my my many knives dude me very good they
did I'm very proud of my knives but just
in case this is something that I need to
actually put up a fight against all
right we're good whatever this is I'm
gonna face it with oh it is giving me
they're giving me some goodies here why
are they giving me goodies I do not know
gunpowder for my collection for my
collection I can't believe I just Oh
save yes probably for the best
hello hello I've got a minigun that I
probably should have used uh oh
how how in the oh my god what is that oh
my god I was horrible
holy [ __ ] I want to throw but I'm gonna
throw myself I'm gonna throw myself into
the mall
we got fit I just want to see what it's
like it's just oh my god
that is nightmarish that is no that's
nightmares that's so horrible that is
that is the worst thing I've ever seen
it's the worst thing I've ever seen
all right okay let's try this again oh
okay I just had to see what the death
was gonna be like hey good to see you oh
you're horrible oh you're the worst okay
what am i shooting exactly
oh okay yeah
[Music]
yeah what is it doing in this car
oh hi gonna live it there you are
you are horrible you are horrible all
right three two one
good
I'm gonna lose that car
thanks Leon
joven I got to do that
bugger
[Applause]
all right goodbye
farewell
Wow Wow Wow
I guess the tyrant doesn't hold a candle
to that Wow no we're just
well we actually just met last night
yeah would have been one hell of a first
date though yeah you have no idea
look he might be able to give us a ride
Oh what if it's not just a city could
Sheree out of here
okay
so is it over yeah definitely yeah oh
yeah but if it's not we'll stop it
whatever it takes yeah you damn right we
will as long as we stick together
we'll be fine we didn't do that the
whole game we didn't stick together even
once we didn't you guys gonna talk to me
[Music]
next up on this boring Wednesday is a
song to get your blood pumping oh okay
that's it they love it
yay we did it okay I gotta get to the
end of this list
let's just go ahead and skip because I
got a feeling okay there's nothing at
the end of it see this because I died so
many times it's probably cuz I had so
many times I hope I didn't get I know if
I didn't miss any end-credit thing just
because I skipped there I feel bad I
probably should have tried but maybe
maybe there was maybe there wasn't but I
think that's yeah I think that's as
end-credit as it gets right maybe if I
just missed something I'm so mad game
mode extra the fourth survivor
what Oh No the fourth survivor what is
that oh it's a time-based thing oh I
didn't know his time base oh so it's not
even to do with saves it's just time uh
so me being completionist about is what
got it all wrong okay so that is
Resident Evil 2 the remake this was
awesome I had a blast I played the whole
game in like two days because I was just
having so much fun with it like I
recorded it all in two days not because
I had to but because I really wanted to
play it in fact I want to play it more I
want to play this fourth survival thing
I don't know what this means but it
seems pretty cool and I want to do that
so I might make a video about this but I
definitely know that I'm going to stream
a hardcore run of this game like I just
want to because I feel like it I feel
like it's fun I feel like it's rewarding
and I feel like it's just gonna be a
good time I'll borrow I gonna do it the
flip flop of what I did before where as
did I did Leon and Claire I'll probably
do hardcore Claire then Leon just to get
the whole experience of it but I'm
probably gonna stream that so if you
want to find out when I'm gonna do that
pay attention to social media let guys
know about that and thank you everybody
so much for watching look forward to at
least one more video in the near future
about this extra mode here but also any
DLC that comes out there was a ton of
DLC for Resident Evil 7 I imagined that
probably gonna load it up for this one
as well I can't seem to go the online
store glide we'll find it out later
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know other secrets I
miss and if you want to play this game
for yourself I highly recommend it I'm
not sponsored by the game in any way but
these games are great they're so
involved they're so fun they have so
much to do and it's just so well loved
obviously by the developers themselves
they put so much work into it and it's
just such an integral akule game and I
love that so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the Resident Evil
7 playlists that have got down in the
description below if you want more
Resident Evil there's tons of videos in
that playlist and look forward to more
self pursuit thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]